ich bitte dich das ist absurd
und warum ist dann alles spurlos
verschwunden bis auf die
überweisungsbelege unserer bank und der
datei auf lukas rechner
diese firma hat für uns gute dienste
geleistet bisher lief alles reibungslos
wir haben 134.000 euro an edelweiß
techniker zeit und wissen nicht wofür
für notwendige technik sagt lukas sagt
mir mein gesunder menschenverstand
ich habe die rechnungen selbst
unterschrieben jetzt ist die
zusammenarbeit mit der firma edelweiß
technik beendet basta können wir uns
jetzt mit den wirklich wichtigen dingen
beschäftigen
ich brauchte eine unterschrift unser
größtes projekt habt ihr unterzeichnet
leider drängt die zeit
außerdem unterschrift wird nichts mehr
oder
damit etwas nicht in ordnung
ich weiß nicht was mit ihr los ist aber
du kannst mir vertrauen
ich wollte helfen wenn ich kann
es tut mir leid es hatte nichts mit dir
oder dem projekt werden viel zu tun weiß
emma es ist wir kriegen das schon hin
ich
foto
ich bringe die unterlagen die sie
gebeten hatten danke
zweimal milch kaffee zum mitnehmen
schmieder kluge mit dem was sie daraus
errechnet haben kommen wir nicht aus
das möchte ich mir erst mal genauer an
hier können unsere basisstationen für
den gesamten tag des shootings aufbau
und alle locations sind in der nähe und
platz für den green screen ich kenne
wirklich schlechtere bedingungen aber
die probeaufnahmen mache ich trotzdem
woanders nichts gegen meine stammkneipe
press tv
wenn ich bitten da die speisen werden
mit lebensmitteln aus kontrolliert
ökologischem anbau ort zubereitet
kriegen sie nicht für einen appel und
ein ei ner schmiede
wir werden uns schon einig davon gehe
ich aus qualität hat ihren preis und
muss mein café schön hast du gestern für
mich damals dank deiner fürsorge geht es
mir schon viel besser keine ursache
ich bin spät dran ich wollte noch bei
youtube vorbei die lupe neuigkeiten über
bringen
danach können wir kuscheln soviel willst
sind dass alle unterlagen dass alles was
ich auf die schnelle gefunden hab ich
glaube im keller hat lukas seiner alten
unterlagen und nachsehen
ich mach das endlich rein ich muss nur
ganz kurz ins büro lager der csu
40 kaffee lieber tee
ja